top level economists are the ones that
come from Extinction universities and
get the prestigious jobs
overwhelmingly living lives where they
are from Elite universities elite
private schools Rich families everybody
I know is from that background and they
have oh no idea what's happening in the
real world they've got no idea
so you have this whole world of
economics
where nobody knows what's happening in
the lives of ordinary people we've got
it's it is crazy it is this is It's
and I you know you look at it and it's
sometimes profoundly depressing I think
you you have to look for the humor in a
way you know you look at these guys like
George Osborne and like Andrew Bailey
and you know they look so smart in their
suits they don't know what the
they're doing they do not know what the
f and the worst of it is they don't even
know they don't not that's how bad they
are
that is seriously in this and and nobody
no good trade in the city gives us they
know we know that they're a bunch of
Millions